so this is a another approach that we
discussed last time it's from a recent
publication that talks about the
proximal origin of SARS coronavirus to
published in March and what they did
there is a very simple analysis simple
from the standpoint of just a few
sequences so let's take a look at the
few sequences that they used and what
are some of the conclusions that they
came to which are described right here
in the abstract so here you can see that
they used only 1 2 3 4 5 6 sequences
those sequences one came from human SARS
co co vid coronavirus 2 so that is that
same sequence that we talked about right
here so it's this MN 9 0 8 9 4 7 and
then they took a few other so for
example one of the previous outbreaks
was SARS not SARS tube this one but the
previous ours which had I believe a
higher mortality rate but it was not as
infectious also originated from China so
they have another human sample and then
three other bat samples one of them is
bat rat g13 which is a very recent
sample which was which is one of the
closest ones to this human ones and then
they have another one of the England
which is Chinese or a Malaysian animal
that we think it might be the
intermediate host right so by comparing
these sequences here what you see is
just the spike glycoprotein and so what
we're focused on here is the receptor
binding domain and then a poly basic
cleavage which we'll look at today later
on but the first thing that they did is
they asked the question well if we just
take these six sequences which one is
the most closed which one is then the
you know less clothes less less and less
so they are in that order right here so
the closest one is this one the bat bad
cheater team the next closest one is
Pangolin a human and then two other bad
sorts right so we know that the human
SARS coronavirus - from all the other
human coronaviruses that we have seen
before is the closest to this human and
SARS but from other animals which is
closer right by sequence similarity they
are these bat and penguin and so what
does that tell us now it tells us that
naturally you would think that if a
virus is already already present in the
human population that variation of the
same virus you know that's a fairly
natural thing to happen right if we've
seen it before let's say we see flu and
then we see flu recurrent humans but a
little bit different so if we see that
similarity to other humans we know that
it came from other humans and that's
natural but if we see it that another
host has
say okay well maybe that host might be
the actual original right where that
came from so that that's the basic idea
of course is a little more detail to it
and we'll look at that more today but
first let's deal with it so last time we
talked about how do we actually measure
the similarity we measure the similarity
at the basic level when we have
nucleotide sequences those nucleotide
sequences contain letters a T C and G
and those letters the combinations of
those letters can change between one
genome and another and they can change
in several different ways we will see
substitutions and insertions and we'll
see deletions and so when we see when we
will start looking at the sequences
today we will see that those deletions
actually are very important and you can
see them as deletions that have happened
if one originated from a more full
genome and there has been a section
deleted or the other way around that
maybe one or two or three letters were
added in the new G and then the
substitutions have also different
significance to them so what might be
the different significance to them well
some mutations are called what's called
synonymous and some are called non
synonymous the anonymous means that even
though the nucleotide changes the amino
acid that that is produced by that codon
does not change right so synonymous like
two synonymous words synonyms they
essentially mean the same thing right
the letters might be different but the
meaning is the same so the same here
right so that language nucleotide
language that has to produce words or
proteins in the sequence language
produces something very similar or
produces something very different so
synonymous means the same amino acid was
produced nonsynonymous means that the
amino acid changed and so those are of
course the more important changes that
we should consider so when we have those
one the nonsynonymous mutations are more
significant than synonymous but then
also the different change which amino
acid changed to which amino acid also
has significance as well and that
significance is going to be important
because of these chemical properties of
amino acids that has a role in how the
protein functions right and so we talk
about that as well so they have
different chemical properties these
amino acids and we'll see the
significance of those right and we'll
see how the sequence is actually a
beautiful language that allows the virus
which is a very small organism compared
to other organisms to make very smart
devices functional devices that we've
called proteins and so these amino acids
as you can see right here
some are polar to change some more polar
charge there some are polar uncharged
and some are nonpolar so nonpolar are
basically your building blocks right so
if you think of bricks you got to build
a wall you use these non polar non polar
bricks right so you got to fill out some
space you got to support the building
that's what you use then the other two
kinds that pull and charged and the
polar are uncharged now they have
different functionality right if you
have a door in the house or if you have
you know something else right so it's
something that attaches to something
else or something that has to go through
something else right those two have
different properties so if something has
to move freely through water it has to
have less friction and less ability to
connect and it has to just flow and and
not get stuck anywhere if something
needs to get stuck somewhere and connect
to something right it has to have other
properties so that's why these different
amino acids are actually very important
their properties are very important so
the change in the nucleotide sequence
that makes a change in the amino acid
changes change is important and
what type of change for example if it
went from polar to polar charged to
polar uncharged right that's a bigger
change than for example from one polar
charge to another polar Church etc so
how can we study these relationships
what we talked about last time is that
we have this concept of phylogenetic
relationship and the phylogenetic
relationship seeks to explain by use of
a mathematical model for example a
Bayesian model which is a probabilistic
model it seeks to explain the time
friends and this process of specific for
example mutations right the likelihood
of those mutations happening at a
natural steady pace this tree describes
that process by connecting sequences so
here at the end we have present-day
species so these would be our studied
samples that we will take today and then
we want to connect them to potential
origin right so this right here might be
an origin we might not know what that
origin is it might not necessarily have
a specific sequence to it but we have
typically a relationship between these
by saying they came from the same origin
and if they came from the same origin
they come directly from the same origin
like here or did they come many steps
through several intermediate hosts right
and so the idea here is that if a virus
goes directly from a bat to a human it
has to have specific adaptations happen
those adaptations cannot happen out in
the air out in the air the virus does
not do anything it doesn't replicate it
doesn't you know change it doesn't
mutate it only changes and mutates
within a host so when we talk about
something coming from something we know
that if a lot of mutations have
accumulated and those mutations had to
have accumulate within one or for two
different hosts that's how we can
connect what we observed today with
those rates of mutation that we know
happen for example at the level of RNA
or DNA or whatever sequence we are
dealing with so that's the crime septal
phylogenetic trees now there are many
different ways of building these
phylogenetic trees many different
methods just like there are many
different methods that are good for
different types of sequences multiple
sequence alignment is something that you
know people have been working on for a
long time so a lot of different methods
have evolved and phylogenetic trees also
were first the idea of progeny of this
evolutionary relationship was introduced
right around Darwin's time and so since
then people have been trying to organize
taxonomic relationships to say something
came from something and now this is what
we observe today what that means is that
we essentially are trying to put our
logic human logic right of organizing
sequences or organizing species that we
know of into some kind of groups and to
some kinds of relationships and we want
to see how our logic of learning and
understanding these sequences is
reflected on the actual data that we can
collect now the visualization of these
trees can look circular or radio in
different ways and they essentially all
have the same elements so you can see
that they all have branches nodes clades
blades are these groups and so what we
are doing is we are just visualizing it
in different ways and we can sometimes
try to incorporate time which isn't
always available by the time but
sometimes we can just for you know
representation purposes visualization
purposes simplify something to look like
this or if we want to incorporate a lot
of timescale into the data we will have
to do some ok just one second
you
you
okay sorry
okay so any questions up until now
okay if you have any questions you can
post them right here in the chat and I
will see them and if you have any
questions or if everything is okay so
the first thing that I do want to
mention is that these sequences of
course do not come to us in an assembled
format right we do not have a full
sequence just coming out of a sample
that we collect and therefore we have to
first of all assemble these genomes
together so the way that this would
typically be done and and here for
example we can start thinking of these
approaches we have a project example
that's not from code 19 but from a
different virus that you can see how a
presence of a virus right so if you
imagine a human sample for example RNA
seek shows us expression of different
sequences in the human tissue right so
or some tissue so whenever we take a
tissue we assume that most of the genes
that are being expressed are linked to a
human gene so they're linked to human
gene we can map that sequence onto a
human gene sequence and find that there
is a fairly good match right assuming
that there are some changes assuming
that there are some mutations etc but
nevertheless there will be a pretty good
match sometimes we will take a sample
from an example a fecal sample or a lung
for example saliva
or you know somewhere something from
belongs and we will see that there reads
that do not match the host genome
none of the genes in the host genome
have any sequences that are anywhere
close to what we are seeing so that is
where and this is a project that speaks
exactly about that this is where you can
see what they did was they took samples
from patient this from the lung fluid
from the supernatant of virus cultures
and so they were used they used RNA
extraction next-generation sequencing
and then they did metagenomic analysis
by mapping these reads that they got
right so what you can do is you can
amplify anything that looks like a viral
sequence from the host samples and then
you can map those reads onto a database
of all of the known viruses or of
viruses that you suspect to be there so
that's essentially what they did they
took those samples from bats they
amplified them and then they started
mapping and you can see right here some
of the genomes that they mapped it on
and compared with different so you can
see that the quality of mapping is
represented by this line right here so
some of the mapping was fairly bad right
impacting majority of these were pretty
bad some one were pretty close that this
bat coronavirus Nissin be 45 that's this
pink line and then they essentially
produced a new sequence which is this
rat g13 right that's where we get this
genome grachi 13 is they produced a new
sequence with consensus from the weeds
that they got and developed the new
genome that I actually produced a very
good high quality right and so another
thing that we will talk about in future
sessions if we arrange those is that the
consensus the genome that we take and
produce a FASTA file from a collection
of samples or from one sample typically
does not reflect the complexity of viral
populations within a single sample or
within multiple samples and there have
been reports already about viral quasi
species in small numbers of patients in
China where instead of looking at FASTA
files at assembled genomes researchers
were looking
at actual reads from patient samples and
mapping all of those reads together to
identify whether there's some highly
conserved groups of sequences and those
are called viral quasi species which is
occurring a lot of time with different
RNA and DNA viruses with RNA viruses
they're much more diverse and so the
dynamics of those populations also plays
a role in the process of infection and
the process of replication because
essentially multiple variations of the
genome put a lot more strain on the
immune system to be able to address
those changes at the same time from the
standpoint of the you know suppressing
that replication process okay so last
time I already introduced you to the
NCBI virus database so let's do this
together now we'll go to hands-on so
before we move on to this part let me
just make sure that everyone has their
account and knows how to log in so the
way that we want to log in and do this
next part is by going to server dot T -
bio info so this is the link okay and
please let me know once everybody is on
this URL
you
so if everybody is here you should have
gotten an email with your password so if
you see right here I'm logged in so you
would see your account with your email
address and then remember that password
is different from your educational login
that's done for security purposes if you
would like to change it and make it the
same go back to the educational site and
change it but we we don't send out the
same password by email for both of the
platforms ok so here what we will do
today there's actually two sections that
are using this phylogenetic analysis and
we will actually use this section right
here called virus quasi species so if
you're logged in already you should be
able to click on this arrow right next
to virus quasi species and go to demo
virus MSA and phylogeny and so by doing
this we'll first understand the process
and some of the options that we have
without first uploading in data and then
we'll kind of find the data and do this
together ok so here let's just kind of
look at an overview of what we have so
we have two big sections beneficial
detrimental mutations and deletions and
then virus quasi species and their
phylogeny what we are seeing is a
section that has to do with
identification of point mutations and
then building consensus conserved
genomes within a fast queue file right
so if you have some fast queue files
from patients you know you know I can
show you where you can find those you'll
be able to use this section in red if
you have only assembled genomes fast the
files you'll be able to use this and in
blue so what do we have here we have to
first load our data by pressing on the
start so
you can see kind of what we are trying
to do right we're trying to build a
phylogenetic tree for example by
analyzing mutations the next thing that
we have available after start is
multiple sequence alignment because
these are FASTA files right so we can't
do anything with read we don't have
reads we don't have to map those reads
are already assembled we have to do
multiple sequence alignments it's a
multiple sequence alignment is basically
the process of comparing sequences but
not just comparing them here's my first
sequence that started on this platter
than a sequencer on that letter right if
one letter change happens everything is
going to be different so we have to
first optimize it right and not just
between a pair between multiple samples
that we have so it's a fairly complex
process to figure out how exactly is the
best way to align them but you know here
what we can see is the alignment
multiple sequence alignment and then we
have to convert the multiple sequence
alignment from the nucleotide level to
amino acid level right so amino acids as
we talked about have different
properties and changes from one property
to the other have greater significance
than changes within the same chemical
group and then we have to also select
the codons right so we're looking at the
changes from amino acids we're looking
at the changes in terms of their codon
position and then after that we can
either select one of these trees which
we'll be able to do once we do the
analysis of our own or we can just
select all of the phylogeny methods and
all of the phylogeny methods will
basically include all of these now there
as I said there are many different ways
to do phylogenetic analysis they were
designed for different purposes beasts
here uses a Bayesian analysis or a model
that represents evolutionary processes
so we will take a look at some of those
and there's at least three
that we would want to look at and then
this process will actually build the
phylogenetic tree and analyze all of the
trees and find the best tree because
you'll see that each one of these
methods will actually produce you know
multiple trees 10 11 fees so we'll take
a look at that - okay and so then when
you click OK
that will be the end so here you click
on end
and you'll see this because we are going
to replicate this analysis or so so we
actually didn't add here the output
files however I did send you by email
and so now let me know if you got those
the files yeah okay so with those files
yeah so please check your email if you
got those files if you have those you
can use those but before we go to use
those let's go to the virus database and
find maybe samples that you would like
to be analyzed okay so let me know if
you have those sequences maybe put it in
chat that you do have them
you
okay great okay so if we go to NCBI
virus which is this link right here okay
so this link okay on this link if you go
there you can just search on Google NCBI
virus this is an easy-to-use collection
of different files and it's easy to
prepare from here the FASTA files that
we will be using in our analysis so you
can see here search by virus so we'll
click here
and here we can start writing Corona
give it a moment and you see that it
will pop up
you
okay and here if you scroll down you can
see the different types of coronaviruses
we already talked about these
okay so we're going to be taking this
Balak around of bias one and what you'll
be able to see is that there's about
3,000 different sequences right so each
one of these is a food or some kind of
an assembled sequence and here you can
see the different lengths right so we
saw in our genome it's about thirty
thousand twenty-nine nine hundred and
something you can see some longer some
shorter so there is already a variation
right so when we talk about twenty nine
nine hundred verses 31 one ninety that's
about one thousand nucleotides
difference right so we're talking about
a lot of insertions compared one to
another right or a lot of deletions
however we want to think about it so
we're not looking at sequences that are
almost identical they're quite different
but right in those big differences and
actually are quite easy to understand
all right so if we take all of these
different viruses let's quickly go look
over here we started looking at this
last time so this kind of just provides
us with a good visual illustration of
this relationship between these
different viruses so here you can see if
you go right here data there's two data
sets here to compare to kind of see how
closely they are related right now we're
looking at a comparison between forty
four coronavirus genomes which
coronaviruses we're looking at we're
looking at kovat 19 which is this one
right here SARS beta coronaviruses and
MERS and so next to each one there's
actually going to be you know some
detail about these genomes these
sequences so as you look at these
sequences gray represents an identical
sequence so if if the bin these are bins
of five hundred amino acids long
you can switch it to be 250 or sorry
nucleotides and you can see how there is
some variation right but what is the
closest so what is the closest if we use
kovat 19 the beta coronavirus 2 if we
use that one as our reference which
group of genomes is the closest to this
novel beta coronavirus who can answer
this question
you
we can just type your answer in chat
okay well that's okay something's
Chinese sorry I don't know okay yeah so
four years seven eight five five four
okay so yeah this one but which group so
so which group stars okay it great so
what we see here is that SARS sequences
right so let's take a look
where are they different so let's take
one of the most different bins and let's
take a look at what we can find here so
we have the referenced and here we have
a Y two seven eight five five four here
we have nucleotides right here we have
amino acids here we have the reference
genome and you can see that both of
these have gaps for example right that's
because of multiple sequence alignments
so here in this bin which is right here
right so this bin has this sequence this
is the reference sequence the red ones
are the different amino acids and here
you can see the sequence at the
nucleotide level and by the way you can
scroll here to see the full bin okay so
that is how dissimilar these sequences
are but this gives us a lot of detail
right so we can go in and see at each
individual position how the difference
is but how do we visualize in general so
in general one of the ways we can look
at it is we can take a look at the
colors this is just giving us the change
but how do we even further kind of see
the relationship between samples and
group them and things like that so we
can take a look down here you can see
some are unexpectedly different and here
for example we have some very different
ones right so why do we think these two
are different how do we know we can take
this sample for example
from here let's go back into our ncbi
virus box instead of into their
environment to search for ok and we'll
just read some of the metadata that we
have available for this so here you can
see that this is middle east so summers
where Asperger's syndrome coronavirus
isolate right why do you think it's so
different from the other ones
you
why do you think when we see the
sequence alignment it looks so different
from either the reference genome or even
from as you can see even within the
group of merged in ohms which are all
the orange ones why do you think it's so
different these two
you
you
you
parcel genome great yeah so exactly so
as you can see right here it says it's a
partial genome right so it's not even a
full genome and you can see how much is
missing right here one to 15,000 so
about half of it is not even there and
so it's quite obvious but it's going to
be very different so how do we further
summarize these relationships for
example if we look at the phylogenetic
tree right we can see that beta
coronaviruses group together but they
have some groups within as well murrs
also have some and they also have some
outliers and then we have the Stars
group grouped together with this
reference genome that we had okay
now let's switch really quickly and look
at the Cova 19 June or Moxxi quences
okay this is the picture of human kovat
19 sequences and you can see how it's
very different from what we saw there
right so the differences are actually
much much smaller and so therefore the
groups are also going to be much more
difficult to understand so now that we
know this relationship between these
different types of difference or fairly
similar genomes let's go ahead and find
the genomes that we would like to use so
we already selected the virus alright so
again what I'm going to be doing is I'm
going to be doing something of my own so
I will show you how you know for example
a question that I might have is okay
well can I find
but SARS genomes so genomes that were
isolated from bats can I find another
host maybe for example a camel MERS came
from camel and could I find a Pangolin
let's see what we have and maybe a human
right or just compare different hosts
and let's see what kinds of genomes do
we have so how do we do that so right
here we have host and here let's start
with human
so we have about 1,200 human ones you
can add another one so let's add here
bat
okay and here you have these different
bags
not too many do we have camel we have a
lot of a lot of artiodactyla which
includes camels maybe we want to be more
specific
you
you
you
you
okay so for you you guys think of what
samples you want to compare and as you
think about it okay
so actually this one has 23 so let's
take this one human and then once you're
ready once you've found the sample
groups that you want to do tell me what
you're going to be looking for right so
just so that I have an idea of some of
the data sets that you guys are thinking
of okay or if you want to first kind of
propose a comparison you can go ahead
and do that okay so let's say humans and
camels and bats okay let's look at
sequence length or not sequence length
look at nucleotide completeness select
complete only if we have incomplete
we'll have a lot of variation that
doesn't come from real variation real
biological variation it will come from
technical variation okay so now we have
a hundred and fifty maybe we don't need
all of them all of the human ones right
so for example we can look at specific
dates
and
okay 109 what geographical occasions
let's just limit it to North America
you
and let's just check what we have here
so I see a lot of human okay so only
human from if we select North America
let's also select Asia
when we get there so again a lot of
human samples
if I want to summarize this data right
so if I want to understand what do I
have in total so here you can see for
example all the camel ones are from
African samples how do I get okay so
here I have nine different genomes okay
so this is a pretty good comparison it
seems to me but it's a little bit hard
for me to understand what do I have so I
have here Africa Asia North America okay
where did all the human ones go
you
as for
what do I have here camo human okay so
not a lot of options actually right but
I have some 13 genomes right here that I
can select from so if I select all of
them and click right here on download I
can download different options for
example what's useful to download is
just this table so that later on when I
get my phylogenetic tree or I get my
sequence alignment I can remember what
were they actually the sample is all the
metadata that I had for my samples right
so I have location hosts and all of that
kind of information so I can download in
CSV format and that will give me that
table if I want to compare nucleotide
sequences I would select here click on
next and download all records or
download selected records and click on
next so that's how I will prepare one
single FASTA file okay however a faster
file for me to then remember which ones
were in which group is going to be a
little bit difficult so instead of doing
this and here I hope you guys understand
the concept here right so out of all of
the nucleotide sequences we can now
select specific types and we can
download them and we will get a faster
file just you kind of see what it looks
like let's download it and see what's
inside
I didn't see anybody's ideas in chat so
if you have any of those you can post
them what exactly are you planning to to
analyze in the meantime I will show you
what the FASTA file looks like so as we
see here there's a title to complete
genome here we have a sequence and right
after that after the sequence where you
will see is the next sequence right so
right here is the next sequence and the
sequence will have a definition what is
the title of the sequence so as I said I
emailed you
as an example a few FASTA files
Merkers SARS coronavirus you can look
there you can take those files in this
next step that we will do or you can use
some of your own ideas that again I
haven't seen anyone write anything but
you can you know put in whatever oh I
see that these links that I was sending
five minutes
so that everybody has the links these
were the links that I posted so everyone
with me still
okay okay so so there
McDowell's Mendoza right it's a that's a
very good comparison for example
Pangolin versus humans but tell me what
are you able to find Pangolin samples
you
exactly you couldn't find them okay so
you can't find them I was sure you where
but not in that virus database another
one came from canine versus human okay
what were you able to find canine
Integra okay um yeah I found them I
found sample in China how many just one
I think so no no there's also one in
South Korea so I think I'm coming across
too right now but um yeah okay so keep
searching and and the point is right so
why am I asking you these questions one
you might have a question might be a
good question scientific question you
might just not have the date and another
option is you might have to go somewhere
else to find the data I'll show you a
few other places where you can find more
data or sometimes if you have just one
or two samples with a lot of variation
think about this if you have just two
samples one is from South Korea one is
from China and you know this is all you
have and you want to compare it to 140
human genomes obviously there's a lot of
risk that you will have an unbalanced
comparison so that's why sometimes you
got to look through all of the data
that's available and kind of you know
articulate a question that could be
answered with data and could provide you
with some more or less believable
reliable answers okay great so I'm glad
to know that you guys are all doing this
continue looking for files I'll show you
the files that I shared
you
okay so here we have SARS so let's take
a look at how many do we have a simple
way to search for how many is to find
this symbol that's one so you can see it
already tells us how many there are
there are five so there are five SARS
five MERS right so you'll see that
there's five of each so we have a fairly
balanced combination here of samples in
each one now the other thing that you
will need is your reference genome and
the reference genome that I will use is
the kovat 19 so this is the accession
number M n909 so let's take a look at
that one real quick on NCBI and by the
way on NCBI itself it doesn't always go
directly to
go to NCBI that doesn't always go
directly to the virus database it take
some time to be updated there so here
one search for this and we want to find
the genome or the nucleotide
now that's strange
it's open it up and see what
fine
there we go okay so this one right we
see that it's the Stars coronavirus -
that's the new one it's got twenty nine
nine hundred and you can see that it is
from China submitted on January 5th
that's that it's the original one so
remember that if we want to have a
reference genome we can have a FASTA as
a reference genome or here you can see
that this one is already organized with
gene information in it and that means
that it will have information about the
protein sequence also not just that the
sequence of nucleotides so if you want
to have a reference genome what you want
to do is download it complete record as
a file and download the GenBank
information right so they will have a
dot GB at the end not a FASTA all right
so now let's go here instead of creating
a demo will actually create a real
analysis so we'll take some time don't
expect this to come back right away the
more sequences you have the longer
sequences you have the more time it will
take but if you start now by the time we
do another one of these workshops you'll
already have something to work with
so we can go to virus quasi species and
the first thing that we need to do is
select the file type again you can use
for this part of the session data that I
gave you or if you already had time to
prepare the data you can do that so
let's go and here we'll use stereotype
FASTA right because we'll have the fast
queue files we have FASTA files here we
need to upload some of that data so here
let's just compare
well let's just compare covert 19 MERS
and SARS so they upload right you see I
have them in different files you can
have them as a single file because if
you will have them from from you know
the virus database export you'll just
have them as one okay here you could if
you have real-time for example you have
a sample that's from 2003 you have a
sample from 2019 you can add those and
the tree will be more aligned to those
real date so we'll be able to translate
evolutionary time into normal time I
don't have that right now and here I
have to have a reference genome so here
I will add the file and I will use that
GenBank file as my reference
four that's four so I was gonna do let
me reset this again I get faster let's
create this again don't select fast that
upload these files
skip skip okay so now we got a press
start we'll just do a very simple
pipeline to today so we'll do multiple
sequence alignment that we did in the
demo then convert into amino acid
positions and then we'll do codon and
then we can choose one of these you can
try all but I'll just try one of them so
I'll do birth death process and here
I'll keep it at nucleotide level and end
okay so this is Mars so I know we'll
karana - - and birth this so again you
can run the exact same pipeline or you
can run a different one and you can also
do different types of combinations of
files because obviously that's going to
play a big role and the output that you
will expect to see now the pipeline
itself produces many different files and
one of them is going to be the
phylogenetic tree as a PDF and that's
going to be the best tree out of the
possible ones that that method produced
but we'll look at different ones once
the pipeline is done it will also give
you the actual multiple sequence
alignments and so here there's an
important part that beyond the
relationship right so let's say when I
look at this tree and let me pull up
this tree just so that we can take a
look at some examples and talk about
them okay so we
this so here's an example output between
so this is actually what we saw on the
sequence navigator where we saw 44
different samples so this is a
phylogenetic of those 44 samples what
can we see in this tree we already
looked at it we had kovat 19 sample that
is most closely related to SARS and less
related to beta coronaviruses and even
less tumors right so how do we interpret
these connections
well these connections show us that you
know these most likely came from a much
recent common ancestor then for example
the novel coronavirus and beta corona
virus that are still in the same clade
if you look right here right now you
also have different methods that you can
try here's the current samples that I
provided you with the FASTA files so
here you can see that they were
separated into different groups group 1
2 3 & 4 and those groups are by type so
you can see SARS coded 19 MERS better
growing by us right so one thing that
you want to understand from this is
whether your understanding of the
relationships between these taxonomies
actually come out in the sequence data
right but beyond this it doesn't
actually give you that much information
you don't know where you don't know how
so the next thing that we want to talk
about today is where to look for once
you have that multiple sequence
alignment is what multiple sequence
alignment actually looks like so now the
question is out of those 30,000
nucleotides where do you actually look
at okay are there any questions up until
now about what we did
or what you want to do I mean you don't
have to run a pipeline right now you can
take your time and run it later but did
you have any questions that you want to
ask okay as you come up with questions
you can put them in the chat I'll try to
impress them so as we saw in here right
let's go back to what was explained
right so this article and you'll see a
few more of similar articles coming out
one of the questions that came up was
whether this virus was engineered in a
biotechnology lab whether it came from a
bat whether there came from a snake
whether it came from a Pangolin what
exactly happened right why is that
important well it's important because we
need to prevent such things in the
future obviously and we don't have right
now an antiviral or a vaccine that
really works well and so we would like
to understand first of all how to not
repeat the same thing that happens right
so if when we know that this came from
penguins or snakes we can just ban them
right if we know that this came from a
variety of different animals that's a
different story right we can't ban
everything and monitor everything so
there's a different strategy for every
one of these answers and so one of the
other concerns was whether this was an
actual engineered virus and the
difference between engineered viruses
and naturally occurring viruses is that
they will not have only a single change
that has a very specific phenotype you
gotta have some biological process that
could occur naturally that can explain
what what happened right and so in this
article okay so let me address
these questions real quick well what did
I you choose for the out-group for
evolutionary time approximations
I didn't choose anything what I
mentioned was that if you have if you
selected a specific sample you can take
two samples and say one is from 2003 one
is from 2019 if your 2003 and 2019 are
specific time points in the phylogenetic
tree then the distances in the
phylogenetic tree could be associated
with real years there so I didn't do
anything but if you find one you can
download two files is what you need at
least and then you'll be able to add
those you can Curie was asking what are
the different beast modes what do they
compare they compare different processes
so they compared for example birth death
process it's a process of a natural
aging birth and death
right so replication in this case is
birth and then the that string not being
there anymore is the death okay
so they're different I will share some
more information I think it's also from
the pop ups but those are just different
beasts
so in fact just let me quickly share
with you a publication on beasts so that
you can take a look so if you just
search online beasts around genetic
genetics so you can see that by Bayesian
analysis and molecular sequences using
MCMC which is want to Carlo simulation
and it does in incorporate some kind of
a mathematical model that analyzes the
sequences to determine a process rights
of some process that has a random
probability of one stage happening from
the next stage and the observed data
helps us build a model that can explain
this process
okay what other questions did we have
okay great questions so okay so again we
need to link this process identified by
a model a model will fit any process
right but then we need to ask a
biological question could this be
explained by about a biological process
that we observe in nature and so to talk
about this let's understand one of the
key proteins in the virus in all of
coronaviruses but it's a similar pattern
that actually occurs in multiple
different viruses including HIV
including flu influenza so this is not a
protein it's a tool protein as a tool
and it's not a unique tool to
coronaviruses coronaviruses have a
specific way this tool works for them so
let's see what's important because that
will help explain some of these things
right here right so right here you see
receptor binding domain holding basic
cleavage site receptor binding domain h2
right and hat which residues are
important to look at it has these only
glycan residues right so we'll look at
some of these concepts and what do they
actually mean in terms of this protein
okay so the spike bicoid protein this is
the actual microscopy image of this
virus and you can see that it looks kind
of like the circle and it's got these
things poking out and so when we talk
about the spike glycoprotein we're
talking about this one right here what
does it look like
well imagine there was in a perfect
world it would be perfectly round and
all of these would be exactly the same
but it looks like this this is an actual
electron microscopy model that was
published of the recent covert 19 so
novel coronavirus spike like the protein
but there's also ones available from
SARS and from
and from others from before so here you
can see that it's basically consist of
these three chains so these three chains
so this is the coding sequence for this
gene is right here this is the S
lipoprotein right around 21,000 position
on the nucleotide sequence and you can
see that it is a trimer so that means
that consists of three exactly similar
components so just to kind of quickly
look at a visual here we go back to seek
nav you can see it right here surface
glycoprotein and if you click here
you'll be able to just twist it around
and see what it looks like so
essentially it looks like a V so that
there's a V here right so let's try it
like this now like this so it's got this
part this part and a part that goes down
and then it has this attachment so this
is in the open form so this protein
opens and closes so we'll take a look at
that in a second what does it do as you
can see right here attaches the variant
to the cell membrane by interacting with
host receptor initiating the infection
binds to human age 2 and these other
receptors and internalization of the bar
iris into the endosome of the host cell
this is conformational changes in that
spike lipoprotein right so let's see how
this happens the spy glycoprotein
consists of two subunits subunit 1 and
subunit 2 and then each have very
important structural components to them
including the signal peptide the
receptor binding domain the fusion
protein peptide repeats 1 & 2
transmembrane domain and then the
cytoplasm domain so if you look at these
two different subunits so this is
subunit one this is subunit two and
these subunits this one is on the
outside and this one is on the inside so
essentially if you look at it from the
top it looks like this shape this is the
closed version so it consists of three
chains and they kind of form this closed
thing together and you can see that
underneath it's got this other part that
looks like that so if we spin it around
you can see that it's sort of like a cap
right so it's a cap that sits on top of
this other structure this top right this
full top has an internal section that's
called the receptor binding domain they
receptor binding domain is what actually
attaches to the to the receptor does
then attach all at the same time one of
these three will attach the receptors to
the receptors pretty small here you can
see they compare this receptor between
different coronaviruses and you can see
that the conserved part is that bottom
part the s2 subunit the more variable is
the top why is that
well obviously different cells types
different cell types different host will
have a different receptor structure so
to connect two different ones and to be
able to adapt to the way different host
function it has two more mutate this top
part than the bottom part the bottom
part we'll talk about its function a
little bit has the same function every
one so this is this top receptor binding
domain and the h2 protein the h2 protein
as you can see these both of these PDB
structures are available on the PDB
sigh so you can see that you have a
closed and then the open and during the
open you see that's one chain is open
connected to the receptor binding domain
or sorry receptor binding domain
connects right here to the h2 protein
right this isn't highlighted now the
bottom subunit so we talked about the
top subunit now we have the bottom and
subunit you can see that it's kind of
like a stick again it consists of these
three different chains that are typed
together these chains are separated
right so you can see that they're
cleaved there's a cleavage site which
means that once this top receptor
binding domain attaches to the ACE
receptor there is a process and this
whole top just falls off essentially and
now we have the functional part so you
can think about it as a robber having a
gun in his coat but once he enters the
bank the gun comes out and it puts the
gun into someone's face right so before
that it's hidden it so it's really
hiding it behind something once it knows
we're close to the cell we're close to
the target the the top comes off and
then the real tool comes out so the
cleavage site is right here you can see
this cleavage site right there and the
cleavage site also is important because
we also have a fusion protein the fusion
protein so actually the the bottom part
has a very specific function right in
that function actually once that top
part is taken off the hat is taken off
this goes through a confirmation process
so it transforms the shape the shape of
this whole protein changes and becomes
flexible it's like a cap that also keeps
everything in place and once it's off
this becomes a dynamic structure and the
structure has a specific function which
only can work after this top part is
cleaved off and the fusion protein
becomes exposed so how do we kind of see
so again we talked about the top part
the key there is the cleavage site and
the receptor binding domain the bottom
part has these important portions the
fusion protein the cleavage site sorry
this is repeated and then these are HR 1
and HR 2 so these are two important
sites for the actual function of the
bottom subunit how does it work
one moment I gotta go see something
happen with one of my kids you give me
just one moment
I'll be right back
okay sorry about that
okay um is everybody still here
so as you can see the process right here
right so the the receptor
binding domain right here attaches to
the h2 protein here there's attached
this whole top comes off something
happens we don't exactly know how it
goes from here here but it then goes up
and you can see that these connects to
the host cell and merge the virus with
the house up and this is what it looks
like where and these are the h1 the Hep
pad repeats so these are h1 and h2 to
connect together is the fusion between
them and so it's the O sequences of how
this process works that are most
interesting for us when we think about
the biological process right so when we
think about this biological process of
adaptation to a different host obviously
there was scepter binding domain is
important what else do you think is
important to look for changes in which
parts of this protein do you think are
important from a standpoint of you know
different hosts different immune systems
what else do you think is important
fusion yes exactly so this process of
fusion I mean imagine this if this table
part came off and nothing happened after
that right so even right now as you know
there's a big effort to produce a
vaccine and the way vaccines are
typically done is they are training the
immune system to recognize something
right so what's the problem with that
the problem with that so on one hand
it's an opportunity because beyond the
structural components right we talked a
lot about amino acids these are the N
linked glycans
that are actually important for a lot of
the ways that this protein works so one
they're important for proper folding so
we see how folding and unfolding and
folding into something else is very
important right but also modulating
accessibility to host proteases and
neutralizing apps so when we talk about
immune system recognizing something as
you can see the protein the the full
viral sorry is hiding behind these
poking out spike glycoproteins right so
whenever the organism is looking out for
something that's coming in right if you
knew that there's a huge thing here
right that contains a foreign RNA it's
gonna sound all the alarms that it has
but it doesn't know because all it sees
are the outside and the outside looks
like small little pieces of something so
it's not a big deal one number two these
molecules prevent it from fully binding
and feeling the shape of this whole
protein and the only thing that's
actually exposed as you can see right
here they're covering everything except
for the receptor binding domain but the
receptor binding domain is closed
together so only when it opens up it can
be really felt so when it opens up right
that's when the immune system could
recognize it but only opens up when it's
close to the cell membrane and it only
works next to cells that it infects
which are epithelial cells so this
process helps hide from the immune
system from being recognized and drives
this whole process of shaping now a lot
of people are focused on this receptor
binding domain but we'll see how this
receptor binding domain actually has
right and we talked about this last time
a lot of variation so let's just look at
conservation of these different areas
between different comparisons that we
were doing before right so here we're
looking at Mars
human versus
the 19 human we know that those two MERS
and novel coronavirus are pretty
different so this is expected the read
here is different the white is similar
this is SARS versus human novel
coronavirus 2 and so you can see that
there's a lot less different right a lot
less read but still a lot of read here
on top so the receptor binding domain is
pretty different this is the difference
between the bad coronavirus rat g13 and
the novel coronavirus to the human one
so you can see it's almost the same
except for some key points in the
structures that we looked at some of the
cleavage right some of the h-help that
repeat one and some of the changes at
the exact point of the receptor binding
right which is expected because
obviously bat is different than human so
some of these changes also occur right
so this is we can look at the changes at
the receptor binding domain with the ACE
2 and you can see that Co the novel
coronavirus is actually almost identical
in terms of the spike glycoprotein
however it does have some variation
right here where the yellow is and that
variation is not necessarily on the
surface so another thing that we're
always concerned about when we are
thinking about these vaccines is how
broad spectrum is it going to be how
flexible is it going to be working with
different viruses that we have now or
that might emerge in the future right
you know this problem from flu flu
vaccine can have six percent
effectiveness I can have sixty percent
effectiveness and that's a big
difference so if we go through the
process of producing a vaccine
vaccinating people it's kind of work for
something that it's going to emerge
that's going to look something like this
right at corona virus that is already
different from previous ones that we
knew like for example stars right
we produced a vaccine from science would
it be effective for this novel
coronavirus maybe not but then there are
other strategies right and so the other
strategies that are not related to the
receptor binding domain could be related
to that fusion process and the process
of actually enter entry into the cell
and we'll see if we have more sessions
like this once we get the results from
our analysis we'll be able to look at
the data that we get from the pipeline
and understand how to find these
important positions on the genomic
sequences see specifically what the
changes are and identify how we can
interpret those changes from the
standpoint of this process of cell entry
and then of course replication which is
another big part of the problem but not
only right there's other specific things
that we have to understand about this
whole process that causes such a heavy
burden on infected patients okay so I
see that we covered a lot today and
we're running out of time so are there
any questions about what we did today
you
you
you
you
okay so let's quickly take a look at
penguins okay so you can see by the way
don't just sit there with you know page
open and wait for it to finish you got
to go back to my pipelines and you'll
see your pipelines and just make sure
that you're monitoring this process you
also get an email notification once the
pipeline is done and that might take a
little bit of time depending on how many
people how many samples and add okay so
let's go to NCBI
you
you
okay so here right you can look at some
of the things that are available right
here so you can see Pangolin coronavirus
by realm of dead angle and individuals
meta-genome right do you remember how we
looked at that paper from the bats where
they originally generated this rat g13
genome so this is essentially what this
is if you go here you see that it has
[Music]
you
so we got to go to the file project back
you
you
you
for example what is this
you
removing that
you
Oh
probably search for Khurana so there's a
FASTA file from Pangolin coronavirus
genomic sequence and again this is yeah
so you can see here that it's a full
genomic sequence if you go right here
send to file and then here you can
download the FASTA file it was put on
20th of February so you know I doubt you
will find many of them I do want to tell
you about another place where you can
register if you're going to be
interested in working on these kinds of
datasets you can register on this GIS
aid or maybe Sona can register and you
guys can do this together I don't know
how strict they are on the registration
but you can see here a lot of this
analysis first of all is done and
constantly updated but there's a lot
more data here let me login again
so you got yeah it takes you know a
couple of days to get your password but
once you do they have a lot more
currently updated information coming
from this pandemic so okay so here you
can browse see there's a lot more the
same idea right you can just look for
complete genomes here they have over
2000 from other places in Europe as well
I'm not sure so let's see damn penguin
here
[Music]
there are a Penguin's once but I started
caring
I'm just one from k9 so yeah so you know
I think with Pangolin on NCBI there's
one there are those raw files from
penguin and I think what would be an
interesting thing to do is to analyze
quasi species of the different viral
strains which would be using fast queue
files and you would use this section
right here but also you know you can use
that one sample just like they did in
this nature paper in the stage of
communications where they compared you
know just three bat genomes one penguin
and two humans and that was a pretty
good analysis any other questions
you
you
okay so no did you want to add anything
to this fantastic ins up lots of
different avenues that they can pursue
their own in terms of you know comparing
different things I think this was
fantastic sigh I did everyone have a
chance to submit your jobs maybe it'll
take a while rate that they can come
back and look at there I don't know when
you're going to have any to look at the
results but if you are going to have
another one I'm not sure right so I I
mean I started this one this morning and
it's at 66% so you know depending on how
many people we have in parallel another
workshop that has quite a lot more
people but not everyone has access to
the platform so let's see it should be
over the weekend for sure maybe it's for
one student it completed okay so there
is a question for you for designing
Maxine's is RBD more antigenic would
using RVD covalent with other structured
domain be a good idea for designing
vaccine did you do that behind it or
what is that worth to RVD for most of
time okay so a very good question about
you know the receptor binding domain
right I think before you ask how to
design a vaccine you want to ask what in
the receptor binding domain the
variation the natural variation that
occurs between different today we looked
at different species right different
hosts but what about within the same so
all humans just covered 19 patients that
would be a question to ask right is
there any variation there and not only
at the level of whole genomes being
assembled add in the like the virus
quasi species or the sub strange that it
might happen at the same time in the
same genome if we do another one of
these workshops
love to talk a little bit more about
other function of this virus and
individual proteins even it's not just
the viral replication that is causing a
lot of the symptoms that we observe it's
also the way that this protein works on
its own and so it would be great to talk
about that because I think there are
some better candidates for vaccines not
just focused on the receptor binding
domain and I'm working with a few groups
that you know are pursuing that round so
I think that they have a very valid
point but another thing to think about
when we talk about these vaccines it's
important to see how vaccines can
utilize multiple multiple different
proteins together and so once you have
vaccines with multiple different
proteins right another question is well
how you package this whole thing right
maybe you need to whole theory on maybe
with some variations that make it safe
so we can talk about that I think
there's a lot of good questions that are
you know going to come up about vaccine
design antiviral drugs but it takes a
lot more time to you know start thinking
about those questions based on David
right so let's at this point focus on
doing some analysis that will give us
good insight into the data and once we
have those results we can start asking
those questions with a more informed
direction
HIV vaccines started cd4 receptor
binding sites on vaccine targets the
interaction zone okay so I'm not sure
yeah so I think that was more of a
comment right so exactly that was you
know there are a lot of things to
consider in vaccine design it's not only
that we train the immune system to
recognize some pattern it's also what
that protein does on its own and what
will the vaccine do on its own right
because when you put in some piece of
protein inside the cell it it and it
does something so there's a lot of
things to consider for vaccine design
the smaller on its own the better safer
but they will put like two parts with
that or even those you know HR one inch
or two bound together yeah those are
good directions for like things like
yeah I don't know how to thank you this
was fantastic and I know that you know
you've created this just for my students
and I greatly appreciate that
I know it's extra work on your part and
I'm sure all of them have learnt a lot
and I'm sure they all appreciate you
quite a bit and so we'll be in touch
I'll be in touch with you I know you're
very busy right now but then let
you know give me some time slots that we
can talk to see how we can format this
into other things so okay sounds great
thank you
and if there's no once the recording is
available I wrong
yeah thank you so much Ilya here take
care thank you